(upbeat music)
- Welcome to Ear Biscuits.
I'm Link.
- And I'm Rhett.
This week at the round
table of not quite as dim
as it used to be lighting.
- Oh.
- We're gonna be exploring the question,
what happens when two friends
go on opposite vacations?
- Opposite vacations, well,
I'll come back to that
but yeah, we brighten it
up a little bit, I mean--
- Not too much.
- Can you go too dim?
I think, yes.
- I think we did for a quite a while.
I just got tired of looking at,
'cause I watch, I listen
back and I watch back.
- Yeah, we got to get those views.
You subscribed?
- Yeah, I--
- youtube.com/earbiscuits
if you wanna watch us talk.
- And I just was like, I
just think it's too dim.
- Yeah.
- Just too dim.
Maybe that's the problem.
Maybe that's our problem,
it's just too dim.
We do it, there is no problem.
We don't have a problem.
- Well you're not--
- You're watching in droves.
- You're not gonna tell
them what really happened.
- What really happened?
- Yeah, Keiko, I'm very happy
with what you've done with
the lighting, thank you.
Thank you.
- The lighting
adjusted a little bit and
it's brighter and we like it.
- So the question--
- I hope you do.
- Is what happens with two
friends going opposite vacations?
One to the icy heights of a mountain
and the other, to the
fiery depths of hell.
That's right, I took I took my wife
on a pre-Valentine vacation.
I know Valentine's long gone by now,
to hell to visit Satan himself.
- Vacation to hell.
- No, no, we went to the to the luxurious
Cabo San Lucas in Mexico.
Mexico, I love it.
I love it down there.
- Beautiful place.
- It's warm,
there's no snow, man.
It was the opposite of what you did.
Now, I--
- And that wasn't,
I mean, people asked if
that was intentional.
- A little fire and ice.
- I almost posted on,
I saw what you posted on Instagram
with you lying down in the sand.
- [Link] Oh, shout out to
@linklamont on Instagram.
- You almost forgot your Instagram handle.
- I wouldn't know, I was
waiting for you to take over.
- Oh, I'm not gonna shout you,
I shout me out, you shot you out.
It's a beautiful arrangement.
I was going to do a post like
yours but lying in the sand,
I mean in the snow.
But it was like, who am
I gonna get to take this?
- Yeah.
- I was kind of out there
and I'm gonna give my phone to Shepherd?
That's not gonna work.
So, I just took a picture of my face.
Probably got more likes anyway.
- That's not what it's about for me, man.
It's about my personal,
let's not get back in at that.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, don't go there.
- But yeah, we're like
fire and ice vacations
which reminds me of Fire and
Ice, the basketball players
from North Carolina State University.
- Chris Corchiani--
- [Rhett And Link] And Rodney Monroe.
- Monroe, there we go.
Rodney Monroe.
So who's Chris Corchiani?
Who's Rodney Monroe?
- Who do you think?
- Chris Corchiani
was the point guard, he was
the dribbler and the passer.
Rodney Monroe was the two guard,
always shooting the shots.
- But who do you think?
You know who was fire and ice.
Are you asking me?
Are you asking--
- I'm ice, man.
Which one of us is,
I know Chris Corchiani was the point guard
and Rodney Monroe was the two guard.
- Which one's fire and ice?
- Oh, that is a good question.
- I know.
- I think, well, when you're
on fire, you're making baskets
and when you ice, you're like,
you're cool under pressure.
So one of them was making lots of baskets
and the other one,
I think Chris Corchiani
was ice 'cause he was cool.
- No, no, man.
Chris Corchiani was fire because
he was like super into it
and like just like crazy!
- Running around like
crazy with a bowl cut.
- Rodney was cool as ice
and smooth, super smooth.
- And this is like the early '90s.
- This is the late '80s.
- Really?
- I think.
Pretty sure.
Yeah.
- But who of us is the
fire and who's the ice?
I'm the fire down in Cabo.
I'm like Chris Corchiani,
running around on the beaches.
You're like ice up there freezing,
you took us off trying to ski.
- I'll take that, I'll take ice.
- Rodney Monroe had a--
- Sublime.
- Close cropped haircut
with one line carved in it
and it was in the middle, I believe.
- I think it--
- [Rhett And Link] It moved.
- From time to time.
It depended his mood.
- It's kind of like the I show glaciers.
You're kind of slowly shifting.
- Chris Corchiani became a--
- [Rhett And Link] Real estate agent.
- In Raleigh and his son played for state
but did not get a lot of PT.
I think it was what they call a legacy,
a legacy spot on the team.
- Okay.
- And.
- But if we're talking about
it and everybody's riveted.
- Guys, we don't know, have any idea
what you're talking about right now.
- Before we get into our vacation--
- Fire and ice, man.
- As is the Ear Biscuit
practice to bring each other
fully up to speed on what happened
because we kept it from each other
in order to share it with each other
and you at the same time,
may I give a blow dryer
relationship update
because in a recent Ear
Biscuit conversation,
I was talking about blow drying
my body with my hair dryer
when I get out of the shower and you said
you've talked about that before.
You're always talking
about it and that's right.
I got an update.
Matter of fact--
- Okay, keep talking about it then.
- I've got a PSA, a public
service announcement
that I discovered this morning.
Ladies and gentlemen if
you like me, take a shower,
exit the shower and then go
straight to your hair dryer,
blow dryer, whatever you wanna call it,
turn that thing on to give yourself a nice
crisp and warm dry feeling,
not only on your hair,
not only on your armpits
but also in your crotch area
like I unapologetically do
with no judgment from my tall friend
with a furrowed eyebrows,
then I've got news for you.
Take your old toothbrush
like I did this morning.
I don't know what you
think I'm about to say
but it's not that bad.
- Okay.
- Take the back off of your blow dryer
and brush the back of your blow dryer
'cause that vent where it sucks
in all the air is getting,
is getting clogged up
with dust and whatnot.
I looked at the back of my hairdryer
and that thing just had a,
I was like, it looks dusty in there.
I gotta get a toothbrush
to get it out and I got,
I thought about filming
this for my Instagram.
I should have done it.
It was so--
- Quite a missed opportunity.
- It was so satisfying to
brush out all of this--
- You unscrewed the back?
- There was like a--
- Or just did the--
- There was a superficial filter,
like a netting thing on the outside
and then there was another
filter hidden inside of there
and it was easily turn a
little bit and pull it off
and whoa, there it is
and I toothbrushed out all of this lint.
I'm like, man, this is satisfying.
I should have Instagrammed it.
Now, we're back to where
I was in this story.
Then I'm like, I put--
- Did it improve the blow?
- I put the cap back on
and, no exaggeration,
three times the blowing power.
- You're really clogged up.
- Like, I mean--
- How old is this?
How long he had this dryer?
You sure--
- Maybe.
- You have your own dryer
and your wife has a different one?
Or you guys sharing?
- Christy came in right after I'd finished
and still naked but
totally dry everywhere.
She couldn't find a wet spot on me.
I could have rolled around in flour
and nothing would have stuck.
- Well.
- She said,
she didn't say anything, in fact.
I said, Christy, and I
pulled out my toothbrush
with all these lint and I'm like,
you can use my toothbrush
to clean out your hairdryer.
She's like I use that one.
I'm like, whoa!
You use this one?
Well, I got news for you.
You're about to get three
times the blowing power.
- You thought she had her own hair dryer?
- I thought she did, yeah.
- Well, you guys need to talk more.
- It was in the middle
drawer but I thought
she had one over there
and I thought it was exclusively mine.
I didn't realize I was
doing her a big favor.
And I was disappointed when
she wasn't as excited as I was
but she didn't turn it on.
Tomorrow morning, she's
gonna turn that thing on.
(imitating a blower)
It's gonna blow her away,
it's gonna blow her across the room.
She's gonna,
she's gonna hit the back wall.
- Maybe you need like--
- It was amazing.
- An air filter in your bathroom
if you've got that much dust.
- Hmm, that's a good point.
- Because the only thing
this filtering right now
is the hairdryer as
it's occasionally used.
- Oh, no, I don't use it occasionally.
I use it--
- It's like
the lung of your bathroom.
- I use it. (laughs)
That's right.
- Hold on,
I know you squeegee.
- I towel.
- You towel off and then you blow dry.
- All right guys, he's engaged.
He's engaged in this conversation.
Yeah, I squeegee with my hands,
but you don't dry off with the towel.
- You don't fully cover the body.
You go head,
underarms and crotch?
- I towel off every
square inch of my body.
- But with the blow dryer.
You don't like go up and down
your legs with the blow dryer.
- No, only the hairiest
areas need to be blow dried.
- Okay.
Do you blow dry your hair
completely in that moment?
- Yeah.
- So you get your hair completely dry--
- I get it.
- Before you style it?
- Now that my hair is a
little longer, it helps.
I use less pomade that way.
- You know that I recently,
not recently but like in the past--
- Mythical Pomade, I might add.
- Year and a half to two years,
basically, all my adult life,
I had blow dried my hair as I was,
I mean, ever since the hair's gone up
which is for a decade or whatever.
I blow dried or is it blew dried?
- Blew dried.
- What verb do you
conjugate when in blow dry?
Blown dried?
- Blown dried, yeah.
- I've blown dried my hair for a decade
and then I decided to stop--
- Dry blown.
- Doing that and instead,
I towel dry the hair
just a little bit and
then I put the pomade,
I put the Mythical Pomade in my hair
while it is wet and let it air dry.
- I've been there.
- And that creates more
activity in my hair,
more interest, more of a wave
but then I have to sometimes
even pay more attention to
my hair after I get to work
'cause it's like it's dry
and then I gotta fiddle with it again
and that's kind of pain, by the way.
- If you want height, you
want your hair to be drier
when you apply product.
I'm not saying fully dry.
- But if you want interest and activity.
- Yeah, you might wanna
stay, you might wanna--
- Stay away from the blow dryer.
I have touched a blow dryer in years.
- I'll give you all the lint--
- 18 months, actually.
- From my blow dryer
and you can deposit it in
the back of your blow dryer
then use it.
- Well, I kind of--
- It will be so inadequate.
- My wife got the Dyson that,
I don't know where the filter is.
In fact, it seems like--
- That's a $5,000 blow dryer.
- It seems like magic.
It's just a circle.
It's the same thing that Anna uses here.
- I'm kind of jealous.
- She's using one of those.
- It's not $5,000 but that
is the most expensive--
- It is an expensive hairdryer.
- I've been thinking about
getting one because--
- Well, you can't put a toothbrush in it,
I'll tell you that much.
Don't try that.
- So--
- Well, we can keep talking
about this for a while.
- Look, #EarBiscuits.
Let me know how much better your life is
now that your hairdryer has been brushed.
- And we are gonna talk about
our fire and ice vacations
but first, we're gonna let
you know that you can pick up
Link's very meta Ear Biscuits shirt
that he's wearing while
making an Ear Biscuit
at mythical.store.
- Man, we got Ear Biscuits on everything.
We got it on the sign,
we get it on my chest,
we got it on my,
what's this, dinnerware?
- Well, you can put it,
you can usually just call it drinkware.
- Drinkware.
- But you could have
it at dinner, I guess.
- Also Mythical Pomade, pick that up
and Mythical hair dryers.
- We don't have those
yet but maybe we should.
Let's compete directly with Dyson.
That sounds like a
great business strategy.
Okay, so how we wanna do this?
- I mean, I could talk
more about hair dryers.
I had a idea for a hair dryer
this exclusively for men.
I know that sounds sexist
but that's what marketing is just who do.
- Who do?
- Like BS.
Like a man and a woman's hair
dryer need not be different.
I mean my wife and I, not to my knowledge,
but in in fact trueness,
do use the same hair dryer.
- But--
- Men and women can
use the same hair dryer
but I do think--
- But if you convince men and women
that they need to have
different hair dryers,
like they've convinced women
that they have to have a different razor.
They've done that.
They convinced them.
They did it.
- They've convinced men
that they have to have
different hair dye.
- Right, oh, yeah.
- Just for men.
- Yeah, you got it.
- Not for women!
- Your hair is different.
Right.
- Unnaturally dark for way too long
and you need to get a grip.
- Yeah, I mean, they've
done that very successfully.
- Right, we can do that with a hair dryer.
- Right.
- It's called the Bro Dryer.
- They've convinced women that
they have to have a razor.
- Did you hear that?
- [Rhett And Link] The Bro Dryer.
- That's good.
- Well, I don't--
- I just made that up, man.
- I think it's great marketing,
I don't wanna feed into it though.
- Yeah.
- I don't wanna feed
into making men and women
think that they have to
have different products
to serve the same purpose.
Woman don't need--
- It's got a pair of
testicles hanging from it.
No, that's, it's got a
beard hanging from it.
- A bulbous pink thing
that looks like an alien
remote control in order
to shave their legs.
They don't need that.
- That's right.
That's right.
But they men needed their own blow dryer.
- I do like that Bro Dryer idea.
- Gets the job done.
The Bro Dryer, gets the job done.
That's the slogan.
- Yeah, come to think of it, I did just,
on Instagram, buy
a shaver.
- What?
- That is intended for manscaping.
- Okay, only, not womanscaping.
You can't scape a woman with it.
- Right, but it's like,
you don't need that.
- I loved watching you.
- It's just like everything that--
- The silence if you
were gonna share this,
that like you had fallen
for your own tricks.
- And then, there's a,
they sent me these wipes.
- Men wipes?
- And it said ball wipes on them.
- Oh, gosh, seriously?
- Yeah, I was like, what?
Wipe my balls?
I don't really.
- What?
- Yeah, I haven't opened them.
- Can I borrow a few?
- Okay.
- We gotta test that out.
- Let's talk about this, bro.
- So you went to Mammoth.
- I went to Mammoth Mountain.
- We teased all these, I
mean, so, in the last episode.
People already knew you when to Mammonth.
- So, I'll just get right to it.
Fire and ice, it's never been more fitting
because speaking of ice,
I know I think I said this
in a tweet or an Instagram
or something, I don't know.
Between--
- It's never as fresh
as is this about to be.
- Between the week,
so the weekend before I
got to Mammoth to ski,
they received 11 feet of snow.
- They received it.
- Now, 11 feet is a crap-ton of snow.
- That's an unbelievable amount of snow.
- I mean we're talking like
basketball backboard height.
- Halfway up the backboard.
Now, the weekend I was there.
- Like Rodney Monroe would
have trouble with that.
- They received another four feet of snow.
So, by the time all was said
and done, 15 feet of snow.
- Wow.
- And I was--
- Well, at least it's good to know
that global warming isn't a thing.
There's nothing.
You know, forget about climate change.
- I see where you're going
with that, Link, mm-hmm.
Link's being sarcastic.
Link understands the difference
between climate and weather
unlike some people who tweet
quite a bit about that.
- I'm pushing Rhett's button right now.
- So, I was nervous about the trip
because we had to leave for London
which we'll talk about next week.
Teaser.
We had to leave for London
the day after I got back.
Like the morning after I got back.
- Yeah.
- And--
- If you get back, I mean
with 12, 11 feet of snow.
- When I knew this other
storm was coming in
and I was just like and
then I was talking to
someone, I don't know who,
I can't remember who was
but they were they were like,
last time I went to
Mammoth, I got snowed in.
In fact, last couple of
times I went to Mammoth,
I've gotten snowed in.
I was like, I can't miss,
I can't not go to London.
And so I'm beginning to worry
and I wanna be very prepared.
Now, I know that
once you go up into the
mountains a lot of times,
chains will be required for your tires.
Now, in previous trips
to Mammoth and Big Bear,
we've had to have chains
for the tires in the car,
like carrying chains is
required in the winter
if you're gonna go to these
mountainous regions, right?
And I am assuming that
applies to lots of places
around the country around the world.
But I've never had to apply them.
And this is one of those
moments where it's like
dad mode engaged.
- Oh.
- You know what I mean?
And I'm like okay, it is
possible that I go up there
and I get to a spot in the road
and they've got a sign
that says chains required
and at that point, I got to
put the chains on the tires
and so I feel like I got to practice.
- Okay, so you bought the chains.
- Well, so, turns out
that the chains that I had
weren't quite the right size.
I put them on
two nights before.
- They were for,
for your previous car, you owned them
or you ordered the wrong ones?
- I think that Jessie had gone to--
- Throwing Jessie under the bus.
- No, no, she went and told
him what kind of car we had
and then they gave us the
chains at like an AutoZone
or something like that and they
just gave us the wrong ones.
So, it wasn't AutoZone.
I don't know what it was.
I don't wanna throw any
particular chain under the bus.
(laughing)
Chain!
But the, get it?
But it was--
- Oh, yeah.
- I don't think she said this
is exactly the size of tire.
So, it probably would
have worked but then,
when I called my local place
after I put these ones on.
- You were in your driveway,
you were like at home
putting on the chains?
- I'm in a driveway.
- Practicing, and they were too big?
- They're a little bit too big.
How would you?
Would you have known?
- I wouldn't have known
if they were too big.
- How would you have
guessed that the chains
go onto your tires?
- You lay it out, you drive on it.
- Exactly.
- And you pick it up
like a diaper on a baby and
you link it on the outside.
- Not how it happens.
That's what I thought
it would have been too.
You do not, you do not drive onto it.
You take it, at least the one that I got,
the car is stationary and you
drape the chain over the tire.
- Okay.
- And then you reach around the bottom,
fasten and then you come around the top,
around the front and fasten
and then there's like a
tensioner that tightens it
and then they give you this extra thing
that's like a bungee cord with hooks on it
and grabs the ring that's on this side
of the outside of the tire
and kind of (zipping),
tightens everything down.
It's actually, and I'm
sure there's other ones
that go on differently
but it's remarkably easy.
I got the kind that--
- But you could tell that it was too big.
- Yeah, but then I went
and got the right ones
and practiced again and I was
like, I think I can do this.
- Oh, wow, that was the
time that you spent,
that you could have been
putting on my carrier
that you refused and I'm
still kind of sour about.
- I'm glad I didn't take their carrier
because the place I stayed,
the clearance for parking
was six foot eight and my car
would have been too tall with the carrier.
- Okay, well that's good for both of us.
- I would have just taken your carrier
and I would have just set
it in the snow somewhere.
It would have gotten
four feet on top of it
and it would still be
in Mammoth under snow.
So, you're welcome for
not taking your carrier.
I get up to Mammoth and I
started to see that lots of snow,
like it went from no
snow, like, I don't know--
- I can't imagine 11 feet of snow.
- If you ever driven up,
you never driven up there?
- No, never been up there.
- So, you drive through this
thing called the Owens Valley
which is there's all this
history of the Owens Valley
and how there was this giant lake up there
and then Mulholland who
Mulholland Drive is named after
and lots of things in LA are named after.
Like I've--
- Owen Wilson's hanging out
up there, Terrell Owens.
- This guy owned or worked for the LADWP,
Department of Water and Power
and then he bought a bunch of land,
all the privately available
land in this valley
and that gave him the water rights
to this giant lake that
they basically drained
and this is where LA got
a bunch of its water from
and now, all this water
that comes into this valley
is pumped to Los Angeles.
It's quite interesting
if you're interested
in the history of the
water of Los Angeles.
- That's another podcast, so.
- But anyway, the trip up there
is just this desolate nothingness
with a couple of towns that you come to,
like it could be a town
and it'll be like 50 miles
and nothing except just these
mountain ranges on each side.
We went through--
- But beautiful.
- Beautiful, absolutely beautiful.
You know Lone Pine.
You probably heard of this town.
There's been like a hundred
movie shot in Lone Pine
including Django Unchained
and a bunch of other ones
that you've heard of.
- Uh-huh.
- And the mountains
right outside of Lone Pine looked,
I kind of looked at,
I was like that looks like the Himalayas
like the way that,
it was these rocky mountains,
just straight rocks
with snow on them
and then I started reading
about it on my phone
once I was up at Mammoth, they were like,
often filmmakers used the
mountains outside of Lone Pine
to pass for the Himalayas
in low-budget movies.
I was like, ha!
- Didn't you feel validated?
- Yahoo!
That's right, buddy.
- You felt low-budget validated.
- Anyway, we get very close to Mammoth
and I see the sign, chains required
and my heart rate goes up a little bit.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I'm like this is the moment of truth.
I've got to pull off to
the side of the road.
Keep in mind that not
only are they getting snow
but it's seven degrees.
- Ooh.
Was it snowing at Des Moines at that time?
- It was just a teeny
bit of snow was starting.
- Was there's snow on the street?
- No snow on the ground.
First of all, I wasn't all
the way to Mammoth and so,
the machines they have that
get the snow off of the road,
it's absolutely amazing
how efficient they are
at getting mounds and mounds
of snow off of the road
and then of course because
they sawed the road,
there was nothing on the
road, it was completely dry
but it was like preemptively
putting on chains.
- Okay.
- Some people weren't
stopping, some people,
I found out later why some
people were continuing to go
but I pull over, I was so
prepared, I had a headlamp.
- Was it night?
- It was already dark.
- Or you just
wanted to wear a headlamp
because you had it.
- I had a headlamp, I
had another little light
that I put under the car,
I had a tarp or a tarpaulin
is the full name for that.
- You got tarpaulin.
- Yeah, so you'd get down on the ground.
- You laid out a blanket for yourself?
- I'd added so hard on the tarp.
- Look, take a picture of
me laying out on a tarp.
- And there's people going--
- Get my headlamp.
- Going past me, you know?
And I'm out there on the
tarp and reaching around
and clamping it down and
hoping that I'm not endangering
the lives of my children and wife.
- That guy doesn't use a Bro Dryer.
- I eventually got it on there.
- Sticks his head out
the window of his Harley.
- And then I get back into the car
and I start driving down the dry pavement
with the chains on the tires.
- That can't be good.
- And then I'm like, where's the snow?
Like, I don't feel right about this.
I'm like, Jessie Google how fast,
I was going like 40.
I was like Google how fast you should go
with chains on your tires on dry pavement.
- What did it feel like?
(imitating rattling)
- It that was crazy but when
you get to a certain speed,
it kind of just all blends together
and it just kind of becomes this low hum.
- I mean just literally, your rubber tires
are wrapped in chains, that's crazy.
- Anyway, 20 to 30.
- 30 miles per hour?
- And so I slowed it down.
It took like 45 minutes to
go the last like 10 miles
and eventually once we got to Mammoth,
there's still no snow.
Like very little snow on,
there's a couple of
icy patches or whatever
but chains were still required
but once you got into town,
that was when they had taken,
it was like driving through a corn maze
but the corn was snow.
- Wow.
- So like,
you can't see anything
except these huge snowbanks.
- Like shops?
- Everywhere.
Like, I don't know how they so quickly
got access to everything.
Like, every parking lot,
and every restaurant
and every shop was completely cleared
but they had just moved all the snow
and snow obviously compacts a whole lot
like if you've got 11 feet
of snow, 15 feet of snow,
that's just falling fresh,
you can squish all that down into,
I don't know, a couple of feet.
- But they probably had
salted it so the stuff melted.
It wasn't like they had to push it.
- The road was still
dry but you were driving
through this corn maze of snow.
- Did you take photos of this?
- No.
- Now, was anybody else
driving with chains?
- Yeah, once I got into
town, everybody had them on.
- Everybody?
- 'Cause it was--
- You're validated.
- It was required.
- 'Cause you were thinking
maybe I should pull over
and take them back off and
that would be admitting defeat.
- Yeah, but it was just
one of those moments
where I was just--
- Dads don't do that.
- I could have paid, in fact,
there were dudes out there.
- Dad don't defeat.
- Charging $40 for to put
the chains on for you.
- Just to put them on?
- They didn't have chains.
They just had the service.
- And tarpaulin 'em, probably.
- Yeah, and they were
like dressed like firemen
which I found interesting and ironic
considering you're on a fire vacation.
- Right, so we.
All right, so we got you to
Mammoth, let's get me to Cabo.
Now, I went to a place that
I've been three years earlier.
Christy and I went to this place.
I'll give a shout out to The Cape.
I really enjoy it.
It's a nice spot.
- I've been there once.
- Not a sponsor, I recommended
it to you and you went.
And then I decided I was
gonna go back and I did.
Of course, when you went
back a few months back,
you didn't go back to the same place.
You went to a different place.
- Nothing against The Cape.
- Northing against The Cape but for me,
it's like I knew what I was gonna get
and I wanted more of it.
- I'm always up for a new thing.
I just wanted to try something.
- Yeah, sometimes I want the same thing.
- And if I hadn't had tried something new,
I wouldn't have gotten Gary
to take that frickin' picture
of me in my watermelon outfit.
- Which brought me back to Instagram.
- Yeah, so again.
- I'm not faulting you.
- You should be happy.
- There's a little
different psychology here
between the two of us.
First of all, it was a shorter,
it was just a short,
well, a longer weekend
so a shorter vacation,
wasn't like a whole week
so I just wanted to have
this relaxing poolside place,
place that I was gonna go
to and I could count on it
because I only had a couple of
days to make the most of it.
It started out much better
'cause the previous time that we went,
we were flying down there and
we were getting on the plane
and the first class was already on
and we had some friends,
I'll call him acquaintances,
well, let's call him
friends, people who knew us.
You know, like hey,
recognize us and we went back
and once we got in the air,
they sent back some champagne to us.
The flight attendant came up and said
this is from your friends in first class
and they gave us champagne
or mimosas or something.
- Who friends?
- It was,
Ran and you know it was them.
- Oh.
- So, anyway, we drink the champagne
and I think there was
this weird interaction.
I don't know for sure
but I think that Christy
had taken an anxiety medication
because she has problems with flying.
- Yes.
- And then by the time
we got off the plane,
she's not feeling great and
then we had to take this taxi,
it's like a 25-minute drive
so we're like taking a
taxi to the place and like,
she's not looking like she feels great.
- This vacation's not
starting great, fire vacation.
Fire alarm.
- And literally, when we
pulled up to the place
and they like open the door
and they're like hello,
welcome to the resort,
like grand entrance type welcome situation
and it's a beautiful place
like right when you walk up to check-in,
you're like looking out over
the beach and it's amazing
and as I'm walking up,
Christy's like I've got to find a bathroom
and like she bolts past me
and like I'm taking in this wonderful view
and I just had this image of Christy
like sprinting past me, sprinting
past the reception area,
turns out she asked them
where's the nearest restroom
but I feel so far ahead of me,
it just looked like she didn't even stop.
She just disappears.
She eventually comes out
until she'd found a bathroom,
she was like throwing up
in the bathroom and stuff
and then she had to go up to the,
right, we checked into the room,
she had to like lay down for two hours.
It's a horrible beginning
of that vacation.
After that, everything
got a lot better for her.
- Well, that's one way to see it.
You start that low, you're
gonna have a good time.
- Maybe I threw her under the bus
with this whole medication champagne thing
but that's what happened and then so,
this time, we didn't make
any of those mistakes.
We get there and everything was good
so we got there all in one piece.
I mean the theme of my vacation
was I don't wanna see no
mountains, I wanna see no snow,
I don't wanna do anything
active like skiing.
I wanted to do the opposite of you.
I wanted to lay flat on the sand,
take one picture for Instagram
and I wanna lay flat on a lounger,
drink some drinks, read some
books, be with my lovely wife.
And that's it and mission
accomplished, man.
It was great.
Especially because it didn't start off
with her sprinting past me.
There was no sprinting to any restrooms.
So, that's now my like
measurement of success.
For you, it's did I
actually need the chains?
- Did you have a photo shoot?
- No photo shoot.
Didn't need it.
Again, I got my picture.
I got my picture, I splayed out.
- Well, my vacation was
definitely very active.
My intention in going on this trip
was this is family practice
for our spring break vacation
which is also skiing, a week of skiing.
- You're really doubling down on skiing.
Like this is--
- Well, this is the year of trying it.
I talked about this when we
did our top moments of 2018
and remember, skiing as a family was--
- Yeah.
- One of my top 10.
And so, I really wanna enjoy that week
and there's a little bit of a dad
kind of making everybody do
this element to the skiing thing
'cause Jessie, she can ski
but she got hurt last time she went
and she's just like I'm just
gonna go and I'm gonna read
and that's what she's gonna
do when we go to spring break.
She's actually looking
forward to just relaxing and--
- Lodging it up.
- Yeah, and so,
but I was like okay, so
this is basically about me
kind of getting the
kids a little bit better
so they can really enjoy
and also so they can,
we can all kind of keep
up with each other.
So Shepherd can keep up
with with me and Locke
and I'm no expert so I don't
and I keep it pretty slow
but Locke sprained his ankle
three days before we left.
- Like bad?
Enough that he couldn't ski.
- Yeah, I mean, it's still,
he wouldn't be able to ski right now.
He gonna be well just when we're going--
- Oh, wow.
- To Colorado and at that point,
he may get re-injured, who knows?
Hopefully not.
- Well, what's he like?
Were you there when,
is he injured in a game or something?
- Yeah, a basketball
practice, it wasn't a game.
Basketball practice.
- Was he like wallowing
around on the ground?
- I wasn't there.
I just knew that he
thought he had broken it.
It was a like a bad sprain.
Like one of those, it like
stays with you for a while
and sometimes bad sprains
can be worse than breaks
but it's not that bad, it's
not like a high sprain,
I think it's a low sprain.
- Did you ask him if he cried?
- No, I think he said he wanted to.
He was like it hurt so
bad I wanted to cry.
- Yeah.
- But McLaughlins, we don't cry.
- Oh, gosh.
And we don't take the chains
off once we put them on.
That's not healthy, man, you
need to pass along some--
- Well, I think you should be able to cry.
- I know you're joking.
- I think you should be
able to cry from feelings,
emotional feelings but physical hurt.
- Physical pain.
- I think you got to
keep the tears inside.
I think that's,
especially at 14.
- I'm a little. (laughs)
- You're almost a man.
- Well, I'm concerned about,
okay, so it's just you
and Shepherd out there
but 11 feet of snow, I know
that that, at a certain point,
it gets a lot more difficult to ski.
- Yeah, well, it had gotten
that and I, recently--
- 'Cause when we went the first time,
the last time we went
with our friend Eric--
- It was Park City.
- I was still snowboarding,
you were trying to ski.
You had switched over.
- Anyway, we were currently,
that's the story where I lost
my phone in the blizzard.
- Oh, yeah.
- I probably have told that
but it was very similar to that
that if skiing and powder
and fresh powder snow
is a completely different experience
especially when you really,
I transitioned into skiing
last year or two years ago, so.
It was very difficult
when I got into the place
and I will tell you exactly
how difficult it was
when I got to the top of the mountain
but I recently upped the
douche factor in my life.
You know I'm always trying
to do that a little bit.
- I didn't know you had any more margin.
- By getting my own
custom fitting ski boots.
- What?
- I mean I'm getting
into this at this point
and you go and you rent the,
my feet are done growing, right?
- One bigger than the other,
we're talking about that.
- Right, and you go and you rent
and you never know what you're gonna get
and you never know what's
gonna end up hurting
while you're out there and
there's everybody's like,
you got to get the custom fitting boots
and there's a custom insert
so I went to this place in Studio City,
I can't remember the name
of it but I highly recommend
the ski boot fitting place in Studio City
and the guy spends time with
you and you take your shoes off
and he like put your foot in this mold
and he makes basically a custom insert
to go into this thing and
picks the right boot for you
based on your foot shape.
- Was that like I'm mold?
Like they poured something
around your foot?
- No, they don't pour it.
You put your foot into this like--
- Slime.
- Inflatable, almost like
memory foam-ish type
pad and you press down
and the weird vacuuming
thing is taking place
and then you bring your foot off of it
and your footprint is completely stuck,
so it's really the bottom of your foot
and then with the sides of your foot,
he gets in a different way.
I don't know, it takes
like an hour and a half.
It's pretty high-tech stuff.
- So did you experience
the benefit of that?
- Nirvana?
Skiing nirvana?
- Foot nirvana.
- Yes.
- It was dramatically better?
- When your foot is,
the thing that most people don't realize
and I was one of these
people is that your ski boots
should be much tighter
than you think it should be
so that your foot is, any
movement inside the boot
is being immediately
transferred into leverage.
You know what I'm saying?
Because it's a little bit loose,
you move your leg and then
you hit the side of the boot
and so if you really want the response,
if you're just, if
you're like a near expert
downhill skier like I am.
So, it might be a little overkill
because I'm definitely not
an expert, that was sarcasm.
I am a, 100% of the time,
thinking don't get hurt,
don't get hurt, don't
get hurt, don't get hurt,
get hurt, don't get hurt
even while I'm having a great time.
I never lose that don't
get hurt, don't get hurt
and I've learned that,
I don't think that's what a lot the people
going down the mountains
are thinking about.
I think they're thinking about,
oh, that looks cool, do that
and I'm thinking don't get hurt.
- That looks cool, do that.
- But--
- I was thinking where did my menu go?
Like I was gonna order
like some fish tacos
but I cannot find a
menu, where's the waiter?
Oh, there he is.
Oh, here's the menu.
It's like that was kind of
the adversity that I faced.
- Well, I had--
- Oh, I faced a little adversity.
- Okay, well, I had a
moment of what I thought
could be near death.
So you want me to save that?
I'll save it, actually.
- I had a near-death experience.
- Okay.
- I got a massage.
We always give our massage updates.
We probably talked about
massages more than anything.
And blow dryers starting to,
it's starting to fight for that position,
for me at least but--
- These are the things you look forward to
as your body left to age.
- I told her that my hip
flexors really messed up
ever since I kicked that
soccer ball in Thanksgiving.
And I was like go hard or
go home but don't go home
so you know what that
means and of course--
- You told her to go hard.
- And then I like,
I said right here, it's really hurting
like I was pointing like
where my hip flexor,
right where the top of
my femur hits my thigh,
or hits my pelvis.
And I'll tell you right now,
she was stretching me out.
Of course I was naked under the sheet
so it's like she had this
way to like take the sheet
and Christy was also in
there with another masseuse.
It was like a couples massage thing
but she would turn me over on my side
and like pick my leg up
like trying to stretch it
but she'd wrapped the sheet
like I was wrapping a baby
in a cloth diaper.
Like that's what she was doing to me.
- Yeah.
- But at certain points, my
entire butt cheek was exposed
and like my knee was being
pushed up across my body.
- That's the best part
of the massage though.
- It hurt really badly
because of this injury I have
and I don't know if she made
it better because still hurting
but well, I'll put it to you this way.
You know how when you're grilling chickens
and if you like, if you've
only cut the dark meat
separate from the white meat
so you've got like a thigh
and a leg that's still together
and then you wanna know if it's done
but if you're a little
anxious to get it on the table
and everyone's eating 'cause
it's getting a little late
and everybody's hungry
and they're like dad,
where's the chicken?
If you take it off a little early.
- Never do that.
- So you don't get that, when
you grab the chicken leg,
you can break it from the thigh.
- It's got a little give.
- And then you're sitting
there grabbing the chicken leg
and before you know it,
you're like ham-fisted grabbing your thigh
with one hand and the chicken
leg with the other hand
and you're just wrenching them apart
to try to pull apart and
have a leg experience
separate from a thigh experience.
- Gotta be careful with that though.
- And you're just (imitating creaking).
Just trying to get the part--
- Just pull the bone
all the way out.
- Right, you'll get the thigh
bone out of all the thigh meat
stuck to the end of the drumstick.
- Oh, I was thinking the opposite.
Sometimes, you pull the
drumstick right out of the thigh.
- Either way, it's not good
when the analogy is to my body.
I felt sure that was gonna happen.
- I doubt that she could pull it out.
- I mean it was like,
I was just having imagery
of that Mortal Kombat
finishing move where like
it got pulls the head
and the spine out of the body.
It's like, she's gonna pull my leg.
- Did you make any grunts or
did you make any signals that--
- I was breathing so heavily--
- She's going too far.
- That Christy told me afterward
that she almost asked me to be quiet.
Like she didn't ask me
are you okay?
- You were ruining
her massage.
- She wasn't gonna ask, are you okay?
(Rhett grunting)
She was gonna ask, can you be quiet?
She's like, why are you breathing so loud?
I looked over, I was just like,
did you see me in my diaper?
- 'Cause you were in pain.
- I love the pain but I got
a go to physical therapy
for this thing.
- Still hurts?
- Yes, still hurts.
That's my near-death experience.
Top that.
- Okay, so, because it
was snowing so much--
- Next time you eat a
chicken leg, think of me.
- And because it was so windy,
the top of the mountain was
closed for a couple of reason.
Like, they're worried about
visibility and avalanches
and wind gusts, like the wind gusts
at the top of the mountain
were over 50 miles per hour
and so they're very like
hesitant to open up the mountain
but I'm with my friend Ralph
who is from Switzerland.
- Yeah, he's Swiss.
- And so this guy like,
well, they come out of
the womb with skis on,
you know what I'm saying?
- They know how to point them.
Toes first.
- And it's really difficult
if you come out headfirst
and you then you've got skis on.
You have to use the
forceps, it's very difficult
but they come out of the womb
and they just go right down the mountain.
They learn to ski before they can walk.
So it's a little intimidating--
- All pregnant women give
birth at the top of slopes.
- Right, well, you're always on a slope.
And so the--
- And the cheese is holy.
- I'm a little intimidated.
You know me, like if--
- Well I know you, you
didn't say anything.
- Right, so when Ralph's
like, oh, they opened up
lifts so and so.
- And you're like (mumbling).
- And he knows the whole mountain.
- I'm not saying anything out loud.
- And he's like you wanna go?
And I'm like, uh, yeah.
I'm not gonna say no.
- Right.
- Again, there's something
in me that I can't say no.
- The chains are on the tires.
- I can't say no.
You challenge me to do something,
I'm gonna get on the lift
even though the whole time I'm
thinking, I'm not equipped.
I'm not equipped for this.
- Something in you.
- I don't know what I
will encounter at the top
because I don't know if
you've established it,
not an expert, I don't handle
the double black diamonds very well.
- Well, going all the way to the top
gives you much more
opportunity to constantly think
don't hurt yourself, don't hurt yourself.
- So, first of all, let me just
remind you how cold it was.
So we're talking about like
minus 15, minus 20 windchill
because you're getting to
the top of the mountain
and you got these wind gusts
and I like fully prepared.
I mean I was like double thermals,
and I'm not talking like
thermals Walmart thermals,
I'm talking about like
Patagonia expensive--
- Oh, gosh.
- High tech thermals.
- Stop bragging about all those--
- No, no.
- Equipment you've been buying.
- No, I'm explaining how warm I was.
- It's the type that when
you look at the liner,
it looks like aluminum foil.
- The kind that have like
special loops for your thumbs
to like keep it really tight on your wrist
and then I've got some
high-tech glove liners
underneath my gloves.
I have this crazy thing that's,
I have a helmet, of course,
but underneath my helmet,
it's a ski mask that
magnetically fastens over my face
like this it has a
little hole for your nose
and then the only thing
showing is your eyes
because it goes up under
your helmet and so then,
there was literally no skin exposed.
No skin exposed whatsoever
and I'm going up this lift.
A, freaking out.
- What is the logo
for douche brand?
- First of all, let me explain.
Every single person on the
mountain looks like me.
So, I wasn't standing out at all.
And when it's this cold,
if you don't have the proper equipment,
you're going to suffer
greatly because I was--
- Well, you could die.
- I did have the right equipment
and I was already freezing
with glove liners and gloves.
By the time I got to the top,
I couldn't feel my fingers.
- Sounds like fun.
- So we get off at the top and--
- You hadn't even almost died yet.
- It has picked, the wind has picked up,
the snow has picked up,
I could see nothing.
Like it was just complete
whiteout up there
and like I'm like, Ralph!
- But they don't let
you back down like that.
- Continue listening, friend.
So we go down and there's this,
I get up there and at
this point, I'm like,
Ralph, I don't know if I can do this.
He's like, just come with me.
And we go down this little incline
and then we get to a place where
we kind of have to make a decision
and we're not gonna go
down the crazy, crazy,
it says experts only.
- He says I won't take you down that.
We go down, there's another
option and I see people going,
it hasn't been groomed
and it's just like two
or three feet of powder
and people who look like
they can ski and snowboard
are going off this thing and
then immediately just falling
into the snow and like
their skis are going,
you know how it is,
when we were with Eric,
your snowboard or skis get in the powder
and then you've got to
have somebody help you out.
- Yeah.
- And I was like, Ralph,
if we go this way,
I'm gonna be like turning,
falling, turning, falling
all the way down the mountain.
I was like, in an hour and a half,
I got to get Shepherd from his lesson
because he was doing a lesson that day.
I was like, honestly, I
don't think it would be wise
and I don't wanna do this to
you, I want you to enjoy it.
So what I'm gonna do is like
you go ahead, I'm gonna go,
first of all, it's like we're
on, what's the, Tatooine?
Yeah, I'm like yelling.
I'm like, I'm gonna go that,
it just the crazy wind and snow.
- You're talking about Hoth.
- Hoth, yeah.
- I was on Tatooine.
- Yeah, Tatooine, Hoth.
- I had a drink in my hand.
- And so I walk, I take my skis off
and begin walking back up to,
and of course, I had skied down to this,
I'd probably skied 75 yards
but it takes no time to do that
walking back up the hill.
My boots were going into
the snow up to my knees.
- Hold on, you were walking back to what?
- Back to this to the lift
to tell the lift operator,
I wanna get on the lift
and go down the lift
to get back down.
- Oh, good, good on you.
- But I start walking back
up the hill and I'm like,
I don't think I'm going to
be able to get to the lift.
- That's impossible.
- Because the snow was so deep.
And then I start breathing so hard that--
- Like where was it up, to your knees?
- Yeah, to my knees, but I kept going.
It took a very long time
to get back to the lift
and I get to lift, there's nobody there
but there's a little house
with like someone in it,
like either the operator or whatever.
- Are you visibly crying at this point?
'Cause that would help.
- I'm getting close but you
can't even tell who I am
which at this point, I'm very happy about.
- Okay.
- You can't identify me at all.
So, I go up to, and first of all,
there's so much snow that you--
- You don't care about dying,
you really care most
about not being identified
while almost dying.
- You can't even get into the thing
so I'm like waving at
this girl who is inside--
- A cottage.
- Just the cottage and she
comes out and she opens the door
and has this annoyed look on her face.
Just right from the start and I'm like,
yeah, I think maybe I've
gotten in over my head.
(laughing)
- Hey.
- And I'm like my friend
taught me to come up here
and I'm not sure I can get down.
(laughing)
- I love it.
I love it.
- And she says, and I'm like,
is there any way that
I can get on the lift
and go back down?
And she's like, no!
- No?
And she slammed the cottage door.
- And I'm like but what do I do?
And she's like just go
back the way you came
and just stay straight.
Take it slow, you'll be fine.
And now I'm like, Ralph is gone.
My buddy in the buddy system--
- He's gone.
- Is gone and so now I'm gonna have to be
getting assistance from strangers
and by the way, the wind has picked up.
She's like on the radio like saying,
we might have to shut it down
like there's not gonna be
anybody to take me down.
Every time people are coming up,
they're falling off of the
lift because the thing is,
the crazy wind is going,
so now I'm thinking, I'm
gonna go down the mountain.
I'm already freezing.
I'm gonna get stuck.
I'm going to be a popsicle in the morning.
This is it.
- You're gonna be preserved.
- I'm going to freeze
on top of the mountain.
So, I go back to where we
had to make the decision
which way to go.
- Did you say, thanks?
- At that point again,
I'm dealing with my pride
the whole time.
Like, I can't, I'm not.
But at that point, when
she's like you can't do it,
you've got to go, I'm like,
well, I guess I had to do it.
At that point, there's no option.
So, I go back and at this point,
I'm asking everyone to make sure that I,
like literally every person,
like do you know the easiest way down?
Like I'm confirming like every seven feet,
is this the easiest way down?
And it turns out that the way Ralph went
was not the easiest way
and I would have been in real trouble
if I had gone where he did.
And it turned out that there was a slight,
the slight incline continued.
Again, I couldn't see.
Like you couldn't tell
if you were about to go off the side.
It was like very, very unsettling
and eventually, I got to,
through this whiteout area
and then got into a place
where they had groomed the
snow way up the mountain,
at that point I was able to get down.
I survived, man.
- I'm proud of you for,
for saying, you know what, I need help.
I can't do this.
But then, I don't feel
great about what happened
because she kind of
forced you to push through
and I kind of feel like
the best thing for you
would have been for her
to say something like,
okay, we're gonna take you
down, you're gonna be safe
but we're gonna strip you nude
and we're gonna put a
banner on it that says wuss.
And we're gonna kind of parade
you in front of everybody.
Made it like a real painful
emotional situation.
I feel like this became like
a triumph that you survived,
a survival tale.
- I wouldn't call it a triumph.
If you had to witness that,
you would not have
considered it a triumph.
- Okay, so you let you did learn a lesson?
- Yeah, I learned I'm not
gonna listen to Ralph anymore
when he says to go up this,
go up the frickin' lift
in those conditions.
- He's not your friend.
- But ultimately, I
had an incredible time.
The second day, when
it let up a little bit,
Shepherd was done with this lesson.
Me and him went out.
I got some of that on the Instagram Story.
Shout out, @rhettmc.
The McLaughlin boys, at least two of them
are taking the mountain by storm.
That's Shepherd.
Locke sprained his ankle.
Loser.
- Got the good stuff.
- But like he's getting so much better
and he's like fearless and he's,
there's so much to know
that there was literally,
like typically, when you go
to a California ski resort,
there's snow on like
this slope that you're on
but in like in the trees, there's not,
there was snow on every single
square inch of the mountain
if you go absolutely anywhere.
We saw a dude as we were
going up the gondola,
a guy who had gone down the
side of the mountain at the top
and gotten stuck on the side of a cliff
and his snowboard was like
on two peaks and he was sitting
there holding himself up
like at the top of a cliff
and ski patrol was
trying to get down there
and like lower something to
him to bring him back up.
- Like he had stopped inches
short of going over a cliff?
- Yeah, like--
- And dying?
- People were going everywhere
because snow is everywhere
and at the top of this
mountain, it's like,
I'm talking like adventure ski
YouTube compilation level
mountain at the top of this thing.
It's ridiculous.
- Crazy, man.
- But Shepherd is like going
into the trees and doing,
he's a nut.
- Listen--
- He was having an incredible time.
- It reminds me of the
pool at this resort I was.
- Right, yeah, yeah.
- I mean it started really
shallow like getting,
oh, it's just ankle deep
and then all of a sudden,
I'm walking, I'm walking, I'm
like this is like knee deep
and then all of a sudden, whoa, boom!
- Over your head.
- There was a step and it was
like up to my belly button.
- I've been in that pool.
- And then I kept walking and walking
and then before I knew it, bam!
I ran smack dab into a bar
on the other side of the
pool that served drinks.
- Oh, really?
- Extreme, man.
Extreme stuff.
- Glad you made it out alive.
- Yeah.
- Did you get any help?
- Well, he made the drink for me.
I didn't even have to do it.
- Okay, good, good.
- And then after I drank the drink,
I had to walk all the way back to my--
- Oh, you couldn't carry
the drink through the pool,
you couldn't swim with the drink?
- I just elected to drink
it all before I walk back.
Then the next night, we went into,
we went into town, well, in the afternoon
and there's this restaurant
on the beach called,
it's highly recommended called The Office.
A beautiful place, like I
mean there's all these seats
on the sand of the beach and
then people are walking by
and you're like watching the sunset.
It's beautiful, I was like,
oh, put us right here on
the edge of the beach.
- That's in like Downtown Cabo?
- Yeah, and--
- I miss that place.
- A little bit off of it.
A little bit south of
like the Downtown area.
Ben recommended it
'cause he went down there
a few weeks ago.
- Because I would not recommend
the restaurant that I went to.
- Yeah, this one was good.
- I'll tell you that.
- So, I'm like, oh put us right here
down at the edge of the beach,
like right the first table
because they didn't wanna put us there
and it turns out there's a reason,
because once you sit down there,
it's like I'm getting a margarita
and Christy and I are taking some pictures
and just lovey-dovey in on each other,
just having a great old time.
And I'm looking out at the
view and then all of a sudden,
people start walking up.
Guys, women, kids selling
stuff, like blocking my view,
like cramping my style.
And I'm talking cotton candy.
- Yeah, I'm at a restaurant.
- I'm at a restaurant and the
dude had like cotton candy
and then there's people
with like making bracelets
and a guy comes up and he
looks at me and he says,
he gave two signals.
He said do you want smoke
or do you want blow?
And he did the thing with
his mouth with the smoke
and they needed a thing
with his nose for the blow.
And I'm like, I don't know
exactly what you're referring to
about I think I do and no, we don't.
So, I didn't get any of that.
I already have a blow dryer.
- That's right, yeah.
- And I don't smoke.
It's not good for you.
- Both of those things covered.
- But then somebody came up.
This woman came up and
she had all of these like,
I thought they were banners
'cause they each said something different.
One of them,
and then I'm like these are wearable.
They're like sashes.
You can like buy a sash and
one of them said butt stuff.
They said all types of stuff,
that's what one of them said.
And another one said bushy.
- Oh.
- I almost bought that one.
- Yeah.
- I thought that would
be funny for my Instagram
but then I'm like I don't
know what that means.
I looked at on Urban Dictionary
and bushy either means stuck-up
or it could mean stupid
and I didn't really believe
that's what it said.
I like wiped it out of my memory
and I texted Christy
before we came in here.
I was like what did the banner say?
She said one of them said bushy.
And I was like, are you sure
that you're not misread it?
- I think something
got lost in translation.
I mean I can think of some
other things it means.
- I don't--
- But it's not the kind of
thing you want in a sash for.
- But that's what urban,
well, they were all very
irreverent type stuff
that like for some reason
people would be compelled to buy
while in they're in Cabo.
- King of butt stuff.
- I don't--
- Do they give you a crown with it?
There's the king of butt stuff.
I wonder if he wants to blow.
- It's an interesting
place down there, man.
- Yeah, it is.
- I didn't--
- Typically.
- I just wanted him to move.
I mean I'm eating--
- I'm currently buying something, man.
- Right.
- I am in the process of buying something.
Don't sell me something else right now.
- I would still recommend the restaurant
but I wouldn't recommend
going all the way down to the beach.
And then I remember Ben
warning me about that
but I was so enamored by the
beach that I forgot that.
Even they didn't wanna sit--
- And they know that.
- Yeah.
- They know that.
Bushy beat.
- I'll say one last thing
about the trip to Mammoth
and that is we're trying to figure out
what to do in the evenings.
The slopes closed like four or 4:30.
Sun goes down pretty early,
we would go out to eat right after that.
And, it's our two families
kind of hanging out
so there's like nine of us total.
- May I recommend butt stuff?
- You can recommend that
but I'm not gonna take
that recommendation.
- And I'm not trying to be weird.
I don't even know what that means.
It's just on a banner on Cabo, man.
- That's clear.
So, I was like what are we gonna do
and I think it may have been,
oh, we went on Netflix
trying to figure out
what we're going to watch.
- Now, you got it.
- And they're promoting Monty
Python and the Holy Grail
or it was like coming up and suggested
based on whoever's profile
it was that we were using
which was the person who
had stayed there before us
or maybe the owner, I don't know.
- Oh, okay.
- When you log in, you're
like who's watching?
Kurt, Susan, Bill?
None of the above.
So we'll pick Kurt.
- Kurt with the K because that's risky.
- We're gonna screw
Kurt's watching history.
But Ralph is like,
let's watch Monty Python
and the Holy Grail with the kids
and see how the humor translates.
- Yeah.
- Which I thought was an excellent idea.
- Yeah, he's talking British,
they're also talking like,
this is '70s.
- Yeah, 1974, I believe.
So, teenage kids go
upstairs immediately out.
A little disappointed but,
so now, we have we've
got the younger kids.
- Jessie's not in there?
- Jessie--
- Even more reading?
- Jessie and Heather are
kind of half watching
but also like on the internet.
- Okay, yeah, yeah.
- They kinda doing that thing.
But Ralph and I and then Shepherd and Ian
are all committed to Monty Python.
And I'm watching them watch it
because I've seen this
movie several times.
I'm reminded when I watch it just how,
A, how funny it is,
B, how it could never be made today.
- It's irreverent.
- It's very irreverent,
politically incorrect.
- I've not watched it all in one sitting.
I've seen many scenes from it.
- Well, the next night
we watched Life of Brian
which is significantly more irreverent
and politically incorrect,
it was made in '79, so,
I'm not sure when the other one was made
but because there's like
three in that series, right?
But anyway, the kids were
like looking at each other
giggling, laughing.
Like all the talk about
the African swallow
or the European swallow.
All these, first of all, you
just remember how many things
in comedy are kind of based on the way
that these guys thought.
- Yeah.
- And the way they presented things,
how many memes there are based on this
and just especially the Holy Grail
is this scene after scene
that you could sort of see
the way that they thought
about this like we're gonna go
and then there's gonna be this interaction
which is based on this that
we think will be funny.
The Knights Who Say Ni
or whatever and like,
like very simple devices
that were just kind of
running to the ground
in very satisfying ways,
the kids were completely
into it the whole time
which was crazy to me.
But then we watched the
Life of Brian the next night
and they they push things a
little bit further by the time
Life or Brian came out.
And so sort of inadvertently showed
our youngest kids a naked woman on screen
for the first time so this
gave them that experience.
- Your Swiss friend, I'm sure didn't care.
- No, of course not.
- In Switzerland--
- Everybody's naked there.
- Right.
- So it wasn't a big deal.
- A lot of snow and a lot of
nakedness, it doesn't add up.
- But there's this moment
where Brian's girlfriend.
Well, not really a girlfriend,
just sort of a hookup,
is really how to describe it.
She's naked and I saw it and I was like,
you know, how do I react in this moment?
Because I could do the
thing where I act like,
oh, Shepherd, cover your eyes!
Which in my mind is communicating,
oh, there's a woman's body,
you should be afraid of it.
So, I was like I'm not gonna do that.
I'm not gonna overreact.
So I just kinda sat there and
I just sort of looked at him.
- You looked at him?
- I just looked at him
and he just had this
smile on his face, like.
- Like a guilty smile?
Like whoops.
- Like no, I'm not supposed to see that.
And it was over before he knew it and,
the next day,
I asked him what he thought about it.
And he was like, it was weird.
Okay.
- The whole movie or that moment?
- That moment.
- Oh.
- But anyway, they actually,
if you're if you're
gonna watch one of them
with your small children,
I might recommend the Holy
Grail instead of Life of Brian.
Life of Brian also is just
a little more, the
jokes are not as simple.
- Well, I don't know because
I haven't seen all of it.
- On all different level.
- You know, Shepard got
Lando to watch a movie
that then we left your house
so we couldn't finish watching.
So, yesterday morning, in
order to get him to leave
without the movie being over,
I told him that I'd watch it with him.
And it was The Pink Panther.
- Original?
- No, not the original,
that was with Peter Sellers.
This was Pink Panther with--
- Steve Martin?
- Steve Martin which is the remake
from the '90s.
I'd never seen it.
- It's since been remade again, right?
- I don't know but he,
he came up first thing in the morning,
got in the bed with me and Christy
and looks at me and he's like
you ready to watch the movie?
And I'm like, oh yeah, I did promise that.
So, like first thing--
- Oh, to finish the movie?
- Yesterday morning, no,
we started it over and,
have you seen it?
- I'm not sure.
- It was really funny, man.
I mean I've been deprived
of a lot of comedy
and I realized that like,
I didn't think I would find it funny
because it's like a lot of
slapstick and it's very,
but there's a whole layer of smart
baked into how this thing was written.
Now, it only got 21% on Rotten Tomatoes
but you know what, I'm
taking back what I said
when it comes to comedy,
probably horror too,
it's not reliable.
I think that at least the
first half of that movie
is if you're in the right frame of mind
and you take it for what
it is, it's very funny.
It is very smart the way
that they have executed
something that is so,
well, not stupid but
oblivious, this character.
Very funny, man, I highly recommend it.
We had a blast, the two
of us just cackling.
And it's all credit Shepherd for that.
- Oh, he's a great
movie critic.
- He loved that movie.
2006, thanks, Jenna, so yeah, it came out.
So yeah, not even in the '90s.
That was a sequel
that we haven't watched yet
but maybe we'll watch that.
That's not our recommendations, though.
Should we go to that?
Let's put a capper on what we've
learned from our vacations.
Fire and ice.
Check your ego at the door.
- Well, again, my mission,
your mission was to relax,
my mission was to prepare
for a longer trip and I was a
little bit worried about like,
it's so cold, it was difficult conditions,
great conditions but difficult conditions,
is Shepard going to be,
kids at that age, they
can go one of two ways.
They can sort of recoil from it
and sort of go into themselves
and then you're like oh, crap
I've already paid for this
week long vacation in Colorado
and now, I'm the only
one that wants to do it.
When we left the mountain on the last day,
Shepherd was like, do we have to leave?
One more run, dad.
And so he's on board.
He was he was the one that
I was worried about, right?
- That's good.
I mean you did sweeten the
deal with the topless woman.
- Right, now he just thinks
that every time we go to the mountains,
we ski during the day
and then we watch naked ladies at night
and I'm gonna have to,
I'll have to correct that vision.
- I feel like there are some things
that have been discussed in this episode
that we're gonna have to
apologize for but not.
- And what did you learn?
- I didn't buy the banner.
- You're not a bushy.
- I might be, still don't know it means.
- Maybe saying no to the
banner makes you a bushy.
- Right.
- Did you learn anything else?
- No, I just learned
what happened with you.
(laughing)
Recs In Effect.
♪ Check, baby, check, baby,
one, two, three, four ♪
♪ Check, baby, check, baby, one, two ♪
♪ Check, baby ♪
♪ Check, baby, one ♪
- I've got a rec.
I watched during the probably 20 of hours
of flight that we took to and from London,
I watched the entire Waco series.
May have heard about this.
- Waco, Texas.
- So it's--
- Town.
- It's on, I think it's on Paramount.
Like the Paramount Network
which a lot of people don't have
but they're trying some things.
They're trying to establish themselves.
- This is the Branch Davidians.
Well, they don't call themselves a cult
but well that's what the
US government call them.
- They were definitely a cult.
So, you remember David Koresh,
the Branch Davidians,
early '90s, there was a,
how many days would you
have said that the standoff
between the Branch Davidians
and the government was?
Because we were in high
school at the time.
I remember hearing about it on the news
but what's your guess how long?
- They talked about it
a long time but I mean,
I'm just gonna guess seven days.
- 50 days.
- 50 days?
- Maybe 51 days.
There was a standoff and it was,
a really interesting,
first of all, I think that back in the,
let me just say that Taylor Kitsch,
however you say his name,
of Friday Night Lights fame.
- [Link] Riggins.
- Plays David Koresh and he's excellent.
He's really, really good, very compelling
and there's other like kind of a who's who
of like sort of supporting
actors from other shows.
- I'm glad he did good because he did bad.
He was in that Disney movie
that cost a whole lot of money.
- Oh, that was a little
bit of an embarrassment.
- And yeah, that kinda--
- But he was great in this.
Showed a lot of versatility.
It's very difficult to
be like taken seriously
and like to be this like
compelling character
with a mullet in that way and
he just kind of nailed it.
But like the side piece
from House of Cards,
like Claire Underwood side piece,
that guy was in it and
then Supergirl was in it
then the blonde curly
headed girl from Ozark.
There's a lot of people you
go, oh, that guy from that,
that girl from this.
And I thought they did,
I really enjoyed it 'cause
I like the historical aspect
but the interesting thing about it
is that there's the story that the FBI
and the ATF kind of put
out about what happened
which is the story that
as a kid in the '90s,
listening to the news, you
get the government story
and I'm not much of a conspiracy theorist
as much as I like to say things
like Finland doesn't exist
for funsies on GMM.
I'm really not really prone
to believe conspiracies
but it's interesting
because the whole series
is from the perspective
of the FBI negotiator
who basically got kicked off
of the job towards the end
and a guy named David Thibodeau
who was one of the cult
members who got out
and kind of made it out
of this thing alive.
And basically, it's like you heard
that this was all the
stuff that was happening
but this is our perspective
on what happened.
So I'm sure that it's biased,
I'm sure that it's not true,
100% true but you've got
sort of the government story
and then you've got the
Branch Davidians story
and it's just very interesting
to see that perspective
like oh, this kind of makes me,
I wonder what actually went
down, but I recommend it.
It's only six episodes so
it's one of those things
that there's not too much of a commitment
to just see the story played
out and it's well executed.
- So, are you a Branch Davidian now?
- No, I'm definitely
not a Branch Davidian.
David Koresh was very wack
and did a bunch of
really ridiculous things
but I don't necessarily think
that they should have been
executed by the government.
- That's the rec for this week.
#EarBiscuits, let us know
what you think about,
I don't know, chains on tires.
Anything else that you
wanna throw out there at us.
Let's keep the conversation
going and you know what,
you can count on us to
speak at you next week
most likely about our
experience in London.
We learned a lot, we experienced a lot.
We shared it with each other but now,
we need to share with you.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
- [Rhett] To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
- [Link] And don't forget to
click on the circular icon
to subscribe.
- [Rhett] If you prefer
to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.